pieces and it's not just those pieces
that are working amazingly look at the
pawn chain as well
it's just a vision in in-game perfection
actually it's not just the porn shade
look at that whole diagonal black has
three pawns black has a knight and a
rook all on the same diagonal
um he should have kept his king back
then on the same diagonal that would
have been beautiful
but okay nakamura he knows that he has
to try something he has to try and
attack some of black's pawns
once remaining paul dropped off but the
night is going to come and defend
the the pawn there you see it on the
board and
then the king will just snake his way in
and
uh start menacing some checkmating ideas
it's game over and like about to resign
yeah or let his clock run out
okay he makes a move he brings this rook
across black's king is just going to
step forward now
too many pawns too much action actually
nakamura resigns without waiting for
magnus to move
wow and magnus raises his eyebrows he
looks a little bit shocked but
yeah there the reaction comes this is
amazing